your surgeon will perform a colon
resection which is the removal of part
of your large intestine if you have
colorectal cancer or a number of other
conditions the colon is a long muscular
tube located at the end of the
intestinal tract
after the stomach and small intestine
digests food the remaining material
passes through the colon where water and
electrolytes are absorbed
the residual stool passes into the last
six inches of the colon known as the
rectum where it is stored until released
most of the conditions that are treated
by a colon resection occur in the layer
of cells that cover the inside surface
of the colon known as the mucosal lining
: resection is usually performed to
treat colorectal cancer one of the most
common cancers other conditions it is
used to treat include blockage of the
intestine
ulcerative colitis and Crohn's disease
trauma to the intestine
colon polyps especially when numerous
and large
complications of diverticulitis
and ischemic bowel
before the surgery you will be given
general anesthesia - puts you to sleep
for the duration of the operation a
breathing tube will be inserted through
your mouth and into your windpipe to
help you breathe
your surgeon will begin by making an
incision in your abdomen over the part
of the colon that needs to be removed
your surgeon will clamp your colon in
two places on each side of the section
to be removed he or she will cut through
the colon at each clamp and remove the
diseased portion in between along with a
margin of healthy colon and surrounding
tissue finally your surgeon will sew the
two loose ends of the colon together
after your surgeon has completed the
procedure he or she will insert one or
two drains to collect fluid that may
accumulate around the surgery site close
the wound with sutures or staples and
cover it with bandages after your
procedure you will be taken to the
recovery area for close observation and
will be given antibiotics and pain
medications as necessary you will
receive fluids and nutrition through an
IV then gradually progress from a liquid
to a solid diet over several days you
will be encouraged to get out of bed and
move about as soon as possible